das zeigt mir dass ich nicht der einzige
bin was überhaupt gibt und alle anderen
rund um spiele das riesen großes theater
und ich werde eine ganz große höhere
macht beobachtet wenn ich mich dafür
natürlich mehr sage ich dass not und das
wird vielleicht sogar noch verbessert
also viel ich werde ich als er eine
inneren erlöse die mit 36 h als ich
wirklich unglücklich alabama ja schon so
das gedankenspiel macht dann muss man
sich fragen wieso blieb den übrig also
dann braucht es hier mit robert oder
denke ich einfach nur der gedanke und
der gedanke allein braucht das terminal
der casio niederzier millionen dankt
woran ich merke dass mich wirklich gibt
ich dann marcel fernseh sein die von mir
selber oder um mich ärgere
die weiß ich mich wieder alles der
verhassten das ist ein ganz großer
release vom weltall dass es mich gibt
weiter